welcome back y'all Kelsey Grammer is
here with
us so earlier we sang the theme song to
his reboot of Frasier which you can now
see on Paramount plus the theme song is
a classic and as are many other theme
songs from great TV shows so it's time
to see how well we will know some of
those shows and songs with a game called
toss salad and scrambled
eggs to and
scrambling yeah
oh Lord are you
there Alpha and Omega is in the house
y'all now listen Kelsey Kelsey you need
a spokesperson for the faith American
Brewing Company I'm your guy okay here's
what we're going to do with this game
I'm going to give you a clue that has to
do with a famous theme song for a famous
TV show and all you have to do is hit
your button and tell me the name of the
TV show show okay all right and if you
lose don't blame me blame the other guy
okay let's go not today Satan yeah
here's your first one okay before his
life was turned upside down he spent
most of his days in West Philly where he
was yeah I was like uh Will Will Smith
it's um fresh prince of Bill air it is
the fresh prince of Bill
air Kelly got yourself a point I I did
have a feeling that if this wasn't my
decade I I I wouldn't have a a chance in
hell okay well Kelly you in the lead so
far with one single point we got
ourselves a game here's the next it why
why that's what God
does he does not I got to keep you
humble I got to keep you humble here's
your next clue okay of this blended
family the youngest one wore curls in
her
hair it is the Brady
[Applause]
buns thank you I don't really remember
that but I thought there was probably
going to be a show so I guess we got
ourselves a TI yes indeed all right
here's your next question okay there are
times you'd like to be in a place where
everybody knows your name if you didn't
get that it would have been real sad
cheers yeah it is
K that would have been real sad such a
big fan I remember Season 2 Episode 16
of frasia that aired February 21st 1995
that's the one where Sam showed up
that's my birthday but I I wasn't in
that one oh I remember like it was
yesterday thank you happy birthday God
bless you for all time okay here's the
next question all time around his
community it was always a beautiful day
in the neighborhood oh I was so quick
did you see that that was pretty good Mr
Rogers yeah it was Mr Rogers it was like
a cat so that was good that was good it
was like a cat like a ninja like ninja
we got a tie we got a tie Fred Rogers
was a saint he was a saint and if you
want to go to the neighborhood to make
believe now just go on Twitter okay
here's your next
question when things are going your way
it feels like you're just moving on up
straight to the top Kelsey Jefferson it
is the
Jefferson that's a good theme song that
was a good theme song them song okay
here is your next question family is
important but in this show everywhere
you looked and every place you went
everywhere everywhere you
is it Family Matters oh oh I'm sorry
does not Family Matters go by fabulous
but is that the same
song No but think about
it it's the well think about it though I
just sing the same
Melody they did that a lot though too
step by step oh my God I can't I'm going
to give you a point I'm going to give
you a point just for that performance
that was
wonderful and it was Full House of
course it was Full House so so what show
is that never Full House never happen
Full House I it wasn't much the paper TV
old
friends okay got it I'm sorry to cut you
off like that Kelly but my therapist
says that that sound means time's up so
here's your last question even God has a
therapist okay that's right yes I got a
lot on my mind let me tell you okay this
one is worth h 100 points why not okay
here we go the most meaningful thing you
can tell someone is simply thank you for
being a
friend Kelsey girlfriends no no no sorry
sorry no no no no no no it's it's the
the Golden Girl golden
girl
girlfriend my God I am forever calling
Golden Girls girlfriends this my
favorite be I love that win for you uh
be sure to watch Frasier on Paramount
plus
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home